programming throwdown episode 104 devops and site reliability with matt watson take it away jason hey everybody so uh if you remember from, I'm on the spot now because I didn't plan ahead. I think it was episode 96. We talked with Rob Zuber from CircleCI about testing. We talked all about all the different forms of testing and how important that is. But at the end of the day, if you're going to have a scalable system, if you're going to service a lot of folks, you're going to have to do more than just write really solid unit tests and integration tests and all of that. I mean, you have to build something that's reliable, that can heal. And you have to build a lot of social and human processes to make all of that work and to keep all of these really popular
Programming Throwdown 第 104 期：DevOps 与站点可靠性，嘉宾 Matt Watson，Jason 请开始你的表演。嘿，大家好，如果大家还记得的话——我现在有点紧张，因为我没提前准备——我想应该是第 96 期，我们和 CircleCI 的 Rob Zuber 聊了关于测试的话题。我们讨论了各种不同形式的测试以及它们的重要性。但归根结底，如果你想要一个可扩展的系统，如果你要为大量用户提供服务，你所做的就不能仅仅是编写非常扎实的单元测试、集成测试等等。我的意思是，你必须构建一个可靠的、能够自我修复的系统。而且你必须建立许多社会和人为流程来让这一切运转起来，并保持所有这些非常受欢迎的
websites that you go to every day stable. And so we have Matt Watson here, who's the CEO and founder of Stackify, who's had a ton of experience in this field and is going to take some time to really share with us how that whole process works and how these websites do stay up for all of that time. And so, Matt, it's really good to have you on the show. How are you doing? Great. Absolutely. Thanks for having me. Cool. Awesome. Are you hanging tight with the lockdown? I don't know what area you're in, how severe the lockdown is right now for you. Yeah. So Stackify is based in the Kansas City area. Half of our employees live in Missouri
你每天访问的网站保持稳定。所以我们请来了 Stackify 的首席执行官兼创始人 Matt Watson，他在这个领域拥有丰富的经验，他将花点时间与我们分享整个流程是如何运作的，以及这些网站是如何在那么长的时间里保持在线的。Matt，很高兴你能来参加节目。你最近怎么样？很好，绝对没问题。谢谢邀请。太棒了。你还在居家隔离吗？我不知道你在哪个地区，现在的隔离措施对你来说有多严格。是的，Stackify 总部位于堪萨斯城地区。我们一半的员工住在密苏里州
and half live in Kansas. For those who don't know the trivia about Kansas City,. Half of our employees live in Missouri and half live in Kansas. For those who don't know the trivia about Kansas City, it's right on the border. Oh, that's right. Yeah. But yeah, everybody's doing good and working remotely and has been no big deal for us. Coronavirus is definitely here, but it's not currently spiking like it is in some other areas. But everybody's trying to play it safe, though. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, it's spiking pretty bad. Actually, both Patrick and I live in Texas and in California.
另一半住在堪萨斯州。对于那些不知道堪萨斯城冷知识的人来说，我们一半的员工住在密苏里州，另一半住在堪萨斯州。对于那些不知道堪萨斯城冷知识的人来说，它正好位于边界上。哦，没错。是的，但大家都很好，都在远程办公，这对我们来说没什么大不了的。新冠病毒确实存在，但目前并没有像其他地区那样出现激增。不过大家都在尽量保持谨慎。是的，这很有道理。是的，疫情确实很严重。实际上，Patrick 和我都住在德克萨斯州和加利福尼亚州。
But yeah, hopefully they kind of figure out ways to get it under control. But cool. So yeah, why don't you start with kind of an intro about yourself? How did you get into this sort of field and what sort of inspired you to take the leap from whatever you were doing at the time to say, I want to start a company, build a company around DevOps and site reliability? Yeah. So I am now 39 years old. Yesterday was my birthday. Oh, happy birthday.
但希望他们能找到控制住疫情的方法。太好了。那么，你为什么不先做一个自我介绍呢？你是如何进入这个领域的？是什么激励你从当时所做的事情中跨出这一步，去说“我想创办一家公司，围绕 DevOps 和站点可靠性建立一家公司”？是的，我现在 39 岁了。昨天是我的生日。哦，生日快乐。
So, thank you. I actually started my first software company when I was, let's see, 22 years old. And it was a company called Vint Solutions, and that company grew really fast. It was actually, it's weird to think about it now, but it was really kind of on the forefront of SaaS, you know, software as a service companies. And back then, crap was hard. Like, if we needed more servers, like, we're racking servers and installing VMware and, like, dealing with all that kind of crap. And, you know, none of that was fun and none of it was easy. And it was before the cloud, right? Before AWS and Azure and all these things. So did you have a warehouse or something i mean how did you see we just used
谢谢。实际上，我在 22 岁时创办了我的第一家软件公司。那是一家名为 Vint Solutions 的公司，发展非常迅速。说实话，现在回想起来觉得很奇怪，但它确实处于 SaaS（软件即服务）公司的最前沿。在那个时候，这事儿很难。比如，如果我们当时需要更多服务器，我们就得去架设服务器、安装 VMware，还要处理所有那些乱七八糟的事情。而且，你知道，这些一点都不好玩，也不容易。那是在云时代之前，对吧？在 AWS、Azure 和所有这些东西出现之前。所以你们当时有仓库之类的吗？我的意思是，你们是怎么……我们只是用了
we just used a local data center i mean it was just a local kansas city data center but um you know so that company really grew really fast and in 2011 we sold it but when we sold it um you know i had about 40 people that worked for me in IT. You know, most of that was software development. But we had every challenge in the world from, you know, how to scale this thing, the performance and bugs and trying to build new features. And like, we had all the problems as a startup, right? And, you know, my goal when I when I left there and started Stackify was to build, you know build a set of tools and a platform that would help developers better understand how their applications are performing, how to troubleshoot basic problems, view errors, view log files, just basic kind of day-to-day stuff, which is a lot of kind of DevOps, SRE kind of stuff these days. But the problem I had back then is it felt like myself and the three or four other developers that were the most important people in the whole company spent all day long looking at
我们只是用了当地的数据中心，我的意思是，那只是一个堪萨斯城的本地数据中心。但是，你知道，那家公司发展得非常快，我们在 2011 年把它卖掉了。但当我们卖掉它时，我在 IT 部门大约有 40 名员工。你知道，其中大部分是软件开发人员。但我们面临着世界上所有的挑战，从如何扩展系统、性能问题、漏洞，到尝试开发新功能。作为一家初创公司，我们遇到了所有的问题，对吧？而且，你知道，我离开那里并创办 Stackify 时的目标是构建一套工具和一个平台，帮助开发人员更好地了解他们的应用程序是如何运行的，如何排查基本问题、查看错误、查看日志文件，仅仅是处理一些日常琐事，这在今天看来就是很多 DevOps 和 SRE 的工作。但我当时遇到的问题是，我觉得我和其他三四个最重要的开发人员整天都在盯着
log files and trying to solve bugs in production, right? When we had like 40 other developers, but they just didn't have the knowledge, the tools, the security access, you know, just didn't have all of those things to really help troubleshoot things. And we just didn't have the tools. So I mean, that was originally the goal was, you know, how do we build a set of tools, help developers troubleshoot basic problems, you know, so that the lead developers don't spend all day doing it. Yeah, yeah, cool. So let's try to unpack, unpack's actually, there's a lot of complexity around just getting some diagnostics into your hand, right? So you have this data
日志文件，试图解决生产环境中的漏洞，对吧？而我们还有其他 40 名开发人员，但他们只是没有知识、工具、安全访问权限，你知道，就是没有所有这些东西来真正帮助排查问题。而且我们当时根本没有这些工具。所以，我的意思是，最初的目标就是：我们如何构建一套工具，帮助开发人员排查基本问题，这样首席开发人员就不必整天做这些事了。是的，是的，太酷了。那么让我们试着拆解一下，拆解其实……仅仅是获取一些诊断信息就涉及很多复杂性，对吧？所以你有这个数据
center. Now most people are using AWS, but let's say you've rented out a portion of this data center and you have some servers on it. How do you go from 100 you know, 100, 1000, 10,000 machines serving some website to being able to look at something on your computer and say, Oh, yep, this this is bad. And this log line is bad. How does that end to end process look like? Well, so I mean, all of these things have changed a lot over time, right? And it used to be, you know, developers and system administrators would would set up all these machines, and you'd have a load balancer and you could log into the server. And of course, you have all the security access, you know, concerns with all those things. Right.
中心。现在大多数人都在使用 AWS，但假设你租用了这个数据中心的一部分，并且上面有一些服务器。你如何从 100 台、1000 台、10000 台为某个网站提供服务的机器，变成能够看着电脑说：“哦，是的，这个有问题，这一行日志有问题。”那个端到端的流程看起来是什么样的？嗯，所以，我的意思是，所有这些东西随着时间的推移已经发生了很大的变化，对吧？过去，开发人员和系统管理员会设置所有这些机器，你会有一个负载均衡器，你可以登录到服务器。当然，你对所有这些东西都有安全访问方面的顾虑，对吧？
But now you fast forward to today and like servers aren't even a thing. We have containers or we have serverless applications. And, you know, now you're deploying a container somewhere and there's one to many of those instances of that container. And yeah, to your point of like, well, how do I get the log files off of a container? Right. It's like there's more and more levels of abstraction from, you know, a developer or anybody in IT to troubleshoot these things there's multiple layers of of automation and abstraction and all of this stuff which makes it more and more difficult to troubleshoot some of these things because you know like we use microsoft azure at stackify and
但现在快进到今天，服务器甚至都不算什么了。我们有容器，或者我们有无服务器（serverless）应用程序。而且，现在你把容器部署在某个地方，这些容器实例可能有一个到多个。而且，是的，回到你刚才说的“我该如何从容器中获取日志文件？”的问题。这就像是从开发人员或 IT 人员排查这些问题的角度来看，抽象层级越来越多了。有多个自动化和抽象层，所有这些都使得排查这些问题变得越来越困难，因为你知道，比如我们在 Stackify 使用微软的 Azure，
and uh we were recently trying to troubleshoot something and i had to figure out how to ssh into a container that was was interesting. Yeah, right. And by the way, I'm an old Microsoft developer, basically, who hates everything command line related. And so I'm not an old dog, but I feel like an old dog now being forced to learn this Kubernetes and all this stuff and Linux. And I'm like, God, why is this so complicated? Can I just RDP into the box and troubleshoot some things?
而且我们最近试图排查一些问题，我不得不弄清楚如何通过 SSH 进入一个容器，这很有趣。是的，没错。顺便说一下，我是一个老派的微软开发人员，基本上讨厌所有与命令行相关的东西。所以我不是老狗，但我现在感觉自己像是一条被迫学习 Kubernetes 和所有这些 Linux 东西的老狗。我心想，天哪，为什么这东西这么复杂？我能直接通过 RDP 进入机器并排查一些问题吗？
It'd be a little easier. But the only way we get access to these things today is to get all the data off the servers, right? So like log data, we got to get the logging data off of the servers, the containers, the serverless app, whatever type of app it is, wherever it is, wherever it's deployed, you've got to get that data
那样会容易一点。但今天我们获取这些东西的唯一方法就是把所有数据从服务器上弄出来，对吧？所以，比如日志数据，我们必须把日志数据从服务器、容器、无服务器应用中弄出来，无论它是什么类型的应用，无论它在哪里，无论它部署在哪里，你都必须把这些数据
off of there and get it to a centralized logging solution, which there are a lot of those. Stackify is one of them. We do centralized logging, but there's things like Splunk or all sorts of solutions that you can throw all of your logging data into. Elasticsearch is another popular one. So how does that work? So if someone wants to use any of these, let's say Stackify,
从那里弄出来，并发送到一个集中的日志解决方案中，这种方案有很多。Stackify 就是其中之一。我们做集中式日志记录，但还有像 Splunk 或各种各样的解决方案，你可以把所有的日志数据扔进去。Elasticsearch 是另一个流行的选择。那么它是如何工作的呢？所以如果有人想使用其中任何一个，比如 Stackify，
they've built some Docker container that has their website business logic. And then how do they connect that to Stackify? They write as part of their code. You have something in every programming language. So if someone's using, let's say, C++ or Node.js or something, they have some line that says, you know, log this to Stackify. How does that work? Yeah, most developers in their applications
他们构建了一些包含业务逻辑的 Docker 容器。然后他们如何将其连接到 Stackify？他们将其作为代码的一部分编写。每种编程语言都有相应的东西。所以如果有人在使用，比如 C++ 或 Node.js 之类的，他们有一行代码说：“将此日志记录到 Stackify。”这是怎么运作的？是的，大多数开发人员在他们的应用程序中
use some form of standard logging framework, right? So in.NET, that's log4j and it's Node.js. It's Winston. You know, in.NET, it's inlog or log4net. So, you know, they use these standard logging frameworks, which help you decide if you want to log to disk or log to, you know, syslog or Windows Event Viewer, rolling files on disk, you know, all these different things, right? And so most of the way you do this is they support different targets or appenders that are syncs, they call them different things.
使用某种形式的标准日志框架，对吧？所以在 .NET 中是 log4j，在 Node.js 中是 Winston。你知道，在 .NET 中是 nlog 或 log4net。所以，你知道，他们使用这些标准的日志框架，这有助于你决定是想记录到磁盘，还是记录到 syslog 或 Windows 事件查看器，或者是磁盘上的滚动文件，你知道，所有这些不同的东西，对吧？所以大多数情况下，你这样做是因为它们支持不同的目标或追加器（appenders），或者叫同步器（sinks），它们叫法不同。
But basically, they're like extensions that allow you to just change your config file to say, you know what? I want to send this logging data to this third-party source now, which could be Stackify or Elasticsearch or whatever the thing is, right? So it's usually a small configuration change. Got it. But that's only one type of logging, right? You've also got logging from the web server. If you want to get logs from Nginx or Apache or IS, that's a different kind of logs, like access logs.
但基本上，它们就像扩展程序，允许你只需更改配置文件就可以说：“你知道吗？我现在想把这些日志数据发送到这个第三方源。”这可能是 Stackify 或 Elasticsearch 或任何东西，对吧？所以这通常只是一个小小的配置更改。明白了。但这只是其中一种日志记录，对吧？你还有来自 Web 服务器的日志。如果你想从 Nginx、Apache 或 IIS 获取日志，那是另一种日志，比如访问日志。
And then you've got server logs, which could be things from syslog or Windows Events. And then now you get to Kubernetes, and Kubernetes has its own logs. Everything has logs. There's logging data for everything, right? Oh, I see. And so it's a combination of if you're the one writing the app, then you configure it in your app. But if there's something like the Windows syslog or the Linux syslog,
然后你还有服务器日志，这可能是来自 syslog 或 Windows 事件的东西。然后现在你到了 Kubernetes，Kubernetes 有它自己的日志。万物皆有日志。所有东西都有日志数据，对吧？哦，我明白了。所以这是一种组合，如果你是编写应用程序的人，那么你在应用程序中配置它。但如果有什么东西像 Windows syslog 或 Linux syslog，
in that case, there's like a Stackify, maybe Daemon or something that trolls that and logs it for you or redirects it for you. Yeah. And as we talk about DevOps sort of stuff today, the challenge is, as a developer, you just want to write code and you can add your own logging and stuff like that, right? But then how you deploy your application and then, you know, install it in dev and QA and some pre-production environment and production and the automation of all that and all the configuration and all the settings and all the diagnostics. And that's just like a whole different world that most developers don't want to deal with or don't know how to deal with, right? Yeah. don't want to deal with or don't know how to deal with right yeah and i think that's where you know devops has kind of come in and there's people who specialize on those things and it's its own craft yeah that totally makes sense totally makes sense like so um i mean it sounds
在这种情况下，会有类似 Stackify 的守护进程（Daemon）之类的东西来轮询它并为你记录，或者为你重定向它。是的。当我们今天谈论 DevOps 之类的东西时，挑战在于，作为开发人员，你只想编写代码，你可以添加自己的日志记录之类的东西，对吧？但随后你如何部署你的应用程序，然后，你知道，把它安装在开发、QA 和一些预生产环境以及生产环境中，以及所有这些的自动化、所有的配置、所有的设置和所有的诊断。这简直是另一个世界，大多数开发人员不想处理或不知道如何处理，对吧？是的，不想处理或不知道如何处理，对吧？是的，我认为这就是 DevOps 的切入点，有些人专门从事这些工作，这本身就是一门手艺。是的，这完全说得通，完全说得通。所以，嗯，我的意思是，这听起来
overwhelming i mean there's yeah a lot of questions here one is you know how do you handle there's just so much data, right? I mean, if I just, if anyone right now, if you're running, and I have to admit I'm on the other side of the table, I've only ever done Linux development. So I don't know too much about PowerShell or Windows, but anyone on their computer running Linux can type dd message, and you'll just see this huge flood of all these things.
让人不知所措。我的意思是，是的，这里有很多问题。一个是，你知道，你如何处理这些数据，数据量太大了，对吧？我的意思是，如果我现在，如果任何人，如果你正在运行……我必须承认我是在桌子的另一边，我只做过 Linux 开发。所以我对 PowerShell 或 Windows 不太了解，但任何在电脑上运行 Linux 的人都可以输入 `dmesg`，你就会看到这些东西的巨大洪流。
Oh, your Wi-fi driver is telling you something and and uh you know thousands of lines just for the computer to start and and your windows server is doing this and everything's doing that um and so it's that's a ton of information when even if nothing really interesting is happening on the computer right and so you multiply that by all the computers that it takes to service whatever this website is or this web service is. And it's just overwhelming, right? I mean, how do developers even know if something's going wrong before it's too late, right? Well, the logging data you're mentioning is really only probably like one
哦，你的 Wi-Fi 驱动程序在告诉你一些事情，还有……你知道，仅仅是电脑启动就有成千上万行日志，你的 Windows 服务器在做这个，一切都在做那个……所以，即使电脑上没有发生什么真正有趣的事情，这也是海量的信息。所以你把它乘以运行这个网站或 Web 服务所需的所有计算机的数量。这简直让人不知所措，对吧？我的意思是，开发人员怎么能在为时已晚之前知道出了什么问题，对吧？嗯，你提到的日志数据实际上可能只占你需要的信息的四分之一。
fourth of the information that you need. There is so much other information that you need that that doesn't even come from your logging so for example like metrics so what is the cpu and memory of the server or you know custom metrics for your software let's let's say for example you know at stackify we receive log messages right so if we want to, we receive log messages, right? So if we want to know how many log messages per minute are we receiving, that's a metric, right? So software produces a lot of different kinds of metrics that can be specific to the application, which could be things like garbage collection or the number of threads being used, like all sorts of diagnostic things, like how many SQL connections do we have open?
还有很多其他你需要的信息，甚至不是来自你的日志。例如，指标（metrics）：服务器的 CPU 和内存是多少？或者，你知道，针对你软件的自定义指标。让我们举个例子，你知道，在 Stackify，我们接收日志消息，对吧？所以如果我们想知道我们每分钟接收多少条日志消息，那就是一个指标，对吧？所以软件会产生许多不同种类的指标，这些指标可能特定于应用程序，比如垃圾回收或正在使用的线程数，所有这些诊断信息，比如我们打开了多少个 SQL 连接？
You know, all that sort of stuff, right? But then you've got things like CPU and memory and system load and, you know, disk space and like all that kind of stuff, right? So you have all sorts of metric data that is at your disposal. But then, you know, most people these days use some sort of profiling technologies
你知道，所有这些东西，对吧？但随后你还有 CPU、内存、系统负载、磁盘空间之类的东西，对吧？所以你有各种各样的指标数据可供使用。但是，你知道，现在大多数人使用某种分析技术，
like application performance management, APM kind of tools, which is what Stackify does. So we profile their applications in production and can tell them, you know, how many times a this third-party web service and all the different things your application connects to, right? So is that hooked into the OS? How does that work? How do you know without the developer telling you if they're accessing a SQL server? Yeah, so APM products like Stackify, like Application Performance Management, and there's other companies that do this like New Relic and AppDynamics and other companies if people are listening and familiar with those type of products and companies. The way all of them work is they basically inject themselves at runtime.
比如应用程序性能管理（APM）工具，这就是 Stackify 所做的。所以我们在生产环境中分析他们的应用程序，并能告诉他们，你知道，这个第三方 Web 服务被调用了多少次，以及你的应用程序连接的所有不同东西，对吧？所以这是挂钩到操作系统上的吗？它是如何工作的？如果开发人员不告诉你，你怎么知道他们是否正在访问 SQL Server？是的，所以像 Stackify 这样的 APM 产品，即应用程序性能管理，还有其他公司也做这个，比如 New Relic 和 AppDynamics 以及其他公司，如果听众熟悉这些类型的产品和公司的话。它们的工作方式基本上是在运行时注入自己。
So while the application is running, they basically manipulate the code, kind of inject themselves into the application while it's running, and then are able to instrument those different things to know when a SQL query is being called, how long it took that call to happen, when an external service is being, HTTP service is being called.
所以当应用程序运行时，它们基本上操纵代码，在应用程序运行时将自己注入其中，然后能够对这些不同的东西进行检测，从而知道 SQL 查询何时被调用、该调用花费了多长时间、外部服务（HTTP 服务）何时被调用。
So that's done through byte-level, code-level injection into the app at runtime. So what kind of programming language do you use for your work? Yeah, so I typically use Python. And so the front-end work that I have done has been mostly using Flask or Django or these things. So for scripting languages like Python and Node.js and Ruby, the APM part of it is actually done with what's called monkey patching. So basically when you execute a query, our library overrides the behavior of that method with what's
所以这是通过在运行时对应用程序进行字节级、代码级的注入来完成的。那么你工作中用什么编程语言？是的，我通常使用 Python。所以我做过的前端工作主要是使用 Flask 或 Django 之类的东西。所以对于像 Python、Node.js 和 Ruby 这样的脚本语言，APM 部分实际上是通过所谓的“猴子补丁”（monkey patching）完成的。所以基本上当你执行一个查询时，我们的库会覆盖该方法的行为，用所谓的
called monkey patching and then our method gets called instead and then we call the original method so we're able to add like that makes sense instrumentation so that's it's called monkey patching which i didn't even know that word yeah yeah i've done this before for um there was a there was an application where the person used just straight Python prints, and I was kind of in a hurry trying to debug something. And so I just created my own print that called the original print, but then also did some other analysis. There you go.
“猴子补丁”，然后我们的方法会被调用，然后我们再调用原始方法。所以我们能够添加……这很有道理……检测功能。所以这叫“猴子补丁”，我甚至不知道这个词。是的，是的，我以前做过这个，对于……有一个应用程序，那个人直接使用了 Python 的 `print`，我当时很匆忙，试图调试一些东西。所以我只是创建了我自己的 `print`，它调用了原始的 `print`，但也做了一些其他的分析。就是这样。
That's how it works. Yeah, when they called a print, they didn't expect to call my print. But as long as you don't really change what returns from the print, it should work like normal. There you go. So that's how this APM kind of technology works on the scripting languages. And it works similar for.NET and Java and stuff. But those languages are compiled into bytecode, right? So that sort of manipulation has to be done in the bytecode, the compiled code.
这就是它的工作原理。是的，当他们调用 `print` 时，他们没想到会调用我的 `print`。但只要你不真正改变 `print` 的返回值，它应该像往常一样工作。就是这样。所以这就是这种 APM 技术在脚本语言上的工作方式。它在 .NET 和 Java 等语言上也类似。但这些语言被编译成字节码，对吧？所以这种操作必须在字节码（编译后的代码）中完成。
Yeah, that sounds really hard. I put that in the hard category. It is really, really, really, add a bunch of expletives, curse words, complicated. Very complicated. I can't even imagine. I mean, I've seen some of these disassemblers and things like that where you give it an executable
是的，这听起来真的很难。我把它归类为“困难”类别。它确实非常、非常、非常——加上一堆脏话——复杂。非常复杂。我甚至无法想象。我的意思是，我见过一些反汇编程序之类的东西，你给它一个可执行文件，
and it'll turn it into C code. But that's about the extent of my experience in that area. And it looked really difficult, especially you have to do it without knowing what the app developer is going to do. You basically have to do it in a way where it works with every app and there's no corner cases. Exactly. And that's rule number one at stack by is we don't crash other people's applications we don't add a bunch of performance overhead and and actually so we support six programming languages at stack five for what we do and
它会把它变成 C 代码。但这大概就是我在那个领域的经验极限了。而且它看起来非常困难，特别是你必须在不知道应用程序开发人员要做什么的情况下完成它。你基本上必须以一种能与每个应用程序兼容且没有极端情况的方式来做。没错。这就是 Stackify 的第一条规则：我们不会让别人的应用程序崩溃，我们不会增加大量的性能开销。实际上，我们支持六种编程语言，
Actually for in dotnet a large part of the profiler is actually written in C code And then so we have to know C to actually large part of the profiler is actually written in C code. And then so we have to know C to actually write a.NET profiler, which is kind of funny. And same thing for, or actually, I'm sorry, it's C++ technically, I believe. Right. But then in PHP, it's also written in C as well. And then Java actually is written in Java. So it's actually a lot easier because of that but i don't know if you've ever done any programming in c but it's a nightmare yeah so patrick actually
实际上，在 .NET 中，分析器（profiler）的很大一部分实际上是用 C 代码编写的。所以我们必须懂 C 才能编写 .NET 分析器，这有点滑稽。PHP 也是一样，实际上也是用 C 编写的。而 Java 实际上是用 Java 编写的。所以这实际上容易得多。但我不知道你是否做过任何 C 语言编程，但那是一场噩梦。是的，所以 Patrick 实际上
uh is uh is the cx he had to step out he has i saw his kids uh coming barreling through the door so uh but he's done a lot of c a lot of embedded uh programming and um yeah, I mean, that, that terrifies me. One time I did, and I totally botched it, but they asked me to do work on a DSP. And it was, it was super, super difficult. I mean, first, I just I wrote it the way I would write, you know, high level C++ code, and it almost immediately ran out of memory. Patrickrick we were just talking about um having to use c to do like a c to c sharp interop to uh to get automatic uh like to get code injection basically into c sharp um that stuff is brutal but i mean well i think there's a lot of intellectual capital that you've built if you can make that work because it's you need a
是……他是 CX，他不得不离开，我看到他的孩子们冲进了门。但他做过很多 C 语言、很多嵌入式编程。而且，我的意思是，这让我感到恐惧。有一次我做过，我完全搞砸了，但他们让我去处理一个 DSP。这非常、非常困难。我的意思是，首先，我只是按照我编写高级 C++ 代码的方式编写它，结果几乎立刻就内存不足了。Patrick，我们刚才在谈论不得不使用 C 来进行类似 C 到 C# 的互操作，以获得自动代码注入，基本上是注入到 C# 中……那些东西太残酷了。但我的意思是，好吧，我认为如果你能让它工作，你就建立了很多智力资本，因为你需要
very specific expertise well you talk about um just software development in general and and how it's changed over the years right like writing programming in python or java or a lot of these other more modern languages is infinitely more easy than writing c++ and i honestly these days i don't even think really a computer science degree is really all that useful to learn about pointers and bubble swords or compiler theory or any of that. It's completely useless. Unless you want to be a C++ programmer.
非常专业的知识。好吧，你谈论的是一般的软件开发，以及它多年来的变化，对吧？比如用 Python 或 Java 或许多其他更现代的语言编写程序，比编写 C++ 要容易得多。老实说，这些天我甚至不认为计算机科学学位对于学习指针、冒泡排序或编译器理论之类的东西真的那么有用。这完全没用。除非你想成为一名 C++ 程序员。
Then it is really critical knowledge that you need to have. But for a lot of the more modern stuff, it's just so much easier not having to worry about all that crap. Yeah, we'll totally pick your brain a little bit later. We'll put a bookmark on that because I'd love to talk more about that is the most popular question we get into the show is, is should I go back to college, right? And yeah, definitely. Yeah, the TLDR, I kind of agree with you, but yeah, we'd love to, let's talk more about that. Oh, go ahead.
那么这确实是你需要掌握的关键知识。但对于许多更现代的东西来说，不必担心所有那些乱七八糟的事情要容易得多。是的，我们稍后会深入探讨你的想法。我们会对此做一个标记，因为我很想多谈谈这一点。我们节目中最受欢迎的问题是：“我应该回大学吗？”是的，绝对。是的，长话短说，我有点同意你的观点，但我们很乐意，让我们多谈谈那个。哦，请继续。
To go back to what we were talking about earlier about collecting the data, right? Like, so we collect, developers need so much data to understand how their applications are performing and troubleshoot things. So we collect a lot of logging data, which can have really, really detailed information in it. It can also have errors in it. So, you know, one of the things we do is, you know,
回到我们之前谈论的关于收集数据的话题，对吧？所以我们收集……开发人员需要大量数据来了解他们的应用程序是如何运行的并排查问题。所以我们收集了大量的日志数据，其中可能包含非常、非常详细的信息。它也可能包含错误。所以，你知道，我们做的事情之一是，你知道，
we collect the errors and we're looking for unique errors. So it's like, oh, we did a deployment today. Well, a few minutes later after the deployment, we want to see, did we get new errors that we weren't getting before? Did we fix some errors? Like all that sort of stuff. And then we talked about collecting the APM data,
我们收集错误，并且我们在寻找唯一的错误。所以就像，“哦，我们今天做了一次部署。好吧，部署几分钟后，我们想看看，我们是否得到了以前没有的新错误？我们是否修复了一些错误？”之类的所有事情。然后我们谈到了收集 APM 数据，
understanding performance, which transactions happen the most, what causes those transactions to be slow. You know, it's this database query gets called way too many times, gets called in a loop, it's an N plus one problem, or it's just very slow, all that sort of stuff. And so it's just the combination of all this stuff from the metrics, the APM data, the errors, the logs. Developers really have to have all of that information together to really understand how their applications are performing and then troubleshoot problems.
了解性能，哪些事务发生得最多，是什么导致这些事务变慢。你知道，是这个数据库查询被调用了太多次，在循环中被调用，这是一个 N+1 问题，或者它只是非常慢，所有这些事情。所以这只是指标、APM 数据、错误、日志的组合。开发人员真的必须把所有这些信息放在一起，才能真正了解他们的应用程序是如何运行的，然后排查问题。
Otherwise, you just have kind of one piece of the story. Yeah, that makes sense. I think another part of this is to tie this to our last episode. In the past episode, we talked with Max Sklar about Bayesian models, about generative systems, and about some of these machine learning things. And you can imagine this as being sort of a generative model. So you could look at the past, let's say, 30 days of your application and say,
否则，你只是拥有故事的一部分。是的，这很有道理。我认为这其中的另一部分是将其与我们上一期节目联系起来。在上一期节目中，我们与 Max Sklar 讨论了贝叶斯模型、生成系统以及一些机器学习的东西。你可以把它想象成一种生成模型。所以你可以查看过去，比如你应用程序的 30 天，并说：
in all of these days, I saw this one error message, you know, about 20 times. So maybe 20 plus or minus two, right? And then now you're on the next day and you see that same error message 400 times. And so, you know, if you had some kind of generative model, it would have expected you to see that message 20 times, you saw it 400, and you could flag that and say, hey, you know, this print with this message is going crazy today. You know, you should take a look at that. And that might be a way for people to find the needle in the haystack, right? Absolutely. And, you know, so machine learning, anomaly detection, all that stuff,
在所有这些天里，我看到了这条错误消息，你知道，大约 20 次。所以也许是 20 加减 2，对吧？然后现在你在第二天，你看到同样的错误消息 400 次。所以，你知道，如果你有某种生成模型，它会预期你看到该消息 20 次，而你看到了 400 次，你就可以标记它并说：“嘿，你知道，带有这条消息的打印今天疯了。”你知道，你应该看看那个。这可能是人们在大海捞针的一种方式，对吧？绝对是。而且，你知道，所以机器学习、异常检测，所有这些东西，
I think is very useful. The challenge we have, though, is that the big problem is that software changes, right? If you deployed some software and you literally never changed it, those patterns would be probably extremely useful because like you just expect the same kind of pattern of usage over and over. And that stuff is great.'re absolutely right but the problem with everything to do with software development is agile development the more stuff changes the more it breaks right like i don't know about you guys but how many times like hey we're doing a deployment today and you all stand around in a room stare at each other for a while and you're like are we really going to do this are we gonna ruin our night weekend is everybody
我认为非常有用。但我们面临的挑战是，最大的问题是软件会发生变化，对吧？如果你部署了一些软件，并且你真的从未更改过它，那么这些模式可能非常有用，因为你只是反复预期同样的模式。那些东西很棒。你是绝对正确的，但软件开发中所有事情的问题在于敏捷开发，东西变化得越多，它就越容易坏。就像，我不知道你们怎么样，但有多少次，比如：“嘿，我们今天要做一次部署。”然后你们所有人都站在房间里，盯着对方看了一会儿，心想：“我们真的要这样做吗？我们要毁掉我们的夜晚或周末吗？每个人都
really sure about this this crappy code we're about to deploy right that's the nature of software development and and now we want to do deployments every week or every day and you have crazy companies like Facebook that I think do deployments every five minutes, it seems like. And those events are the problem, right? And so that's why tools like Stackify and all this data we're talking about are so important because they help give you more visibility. They give you more confidence and they help you understand your risk, right? You're like, well, we know we're going to deploy this. identify, you know, understand your risk, right? You're like, well, we know we're going to deploy this. Like we, you know, none of us feel a hundred percent about this thing, but we know five minutes after we do the deployment, we have all the data we need to understand that all of a sudden there is nobody using our software. Like it doesn't work anymore.
真的确定我们要部署这段烂代码吗？”这就是软件开发的本质。现在我们想每周或每天进行部署，而且你有像 Facebook 这样疯狂的公司，似乎每五分钟就进行一次部署。而这些事件就是问题所在，对吧？这就是为什么像 Stackify 这样的工具以及我们谈论的所有这些数据如此重要的原因，因为它们有助于给你更多的可见性。它们给你更多的信心，并帮助你了解你的风险，对吧？你会想：“好吧，我们知道我们要部署这个。我们，你知道，我们中没有人对这个东西有百分之百的把握，但我们知道在我们进行部署五分钟后，我们就拥有了理解所有事情所需的所有数据，比如突然没有人使用我们的软件了。它不再工作了。”
It crashed or like it's getting all sorts of new errors or performances, you know, dramatically worse, right? So that's really important for all developers to have access to this kind of data because it helps them know when they do a deployment, did things get better or worse? Did like, did we just jump off a cliff? Is the system down, right? How do you deal with that? Like, so let's say there's a deployment and things change, you know, you don't really know whether the change is normal, you know, the deployment caused, you know, the system to just behave differently, or if the change is a problem, there's really no way to know, right? You just have to kind of tell developers about all the changes, right? Or is
它崩溃了，或者它出现了各种各样的新错误，或者性能，你知道，急剧恶化，对吧？所以对于所有开发人员来说，能够访问这类数据非常重要，因为它有助于他们在进行部署时知道事情是变好了还是变坏了。我们是直接跳下了悬崖吗？系统宕机了吗？你如何处理这个问题？比如，假设有一次部署，事情发生了变化，你知道，你真的不知道这种变化是正常的，你知道，部署导致系统表现不同，还是这种变化是一个问题，真的没有办法知道，对吧？你只能告诉开发人员所有的变化，对吧？或者
there, how can you, how can people be smart about that? Well, I think in general, it comes down to having good application monitoring. You know, so you have some baselines, you know, like, you know, this application gets 35,000 requests a minute. Kind of to your point earlier, like there's a very steady amount of traffic, you know, on a monthly basis.
有吗？人们怎么能对此保持聪明呢？嗯，我认为总的来说，这归结为拥有良好的应用程序监控。你知道，所以你有一些基准，你知道，比如，这个应用程序每分钟接收 35,000 个请求。有点回到你刚才说的，比如每个月都有非常稳定的流量，
It's very kind of predictable. And that's, hey, we did a deployment. Okay, well, you know, five minutes after the deployment is, the deployment, are things normal? Is the average transaction times are normal? All that sort of stuff, right? And able to just see, hey, things are behaving in a normal pattern. Or all of a sudden, things are just totally different.
它是非常可预测的。这就是，“嘿，我们做了一次部署。好吧，你知道，部署五分钟后，事情正常吗？平均事务时间正常吗？”所有这些事情，对吧？并且能够看到，“嘿，事情正以正常的模式运行。”或者突然之间，事情完全不同了。
Something has totally gone off the rails. Like, oh, okay, things have gone totally off the rails. Well, hopefully, if you have the right data and the tools, you know, products like Stackify and these things, right, you can go and it's like, oh, wow, this database query is performing terrible now. And I can clearly see, like, the software will tell you, like, wow, this query sucks.
事情完全失控了。比如，“哦，好吧，事情完全失控了。”好吧，希望如果你有正确的数据和工具，像 Stackify 这样的产品，对吧，你可以去查看，就像，“哦，哇，这个数据库查询现在表现得很糟糕。”我可以清楚地看到，软件会告诉你，“哇，这个查询太烂了。”
I don't know what happened, but when we did the deployment five minutes ago, all of a sudden, this database query is crazy slow. And then that helps give you something to pull on, right? Like, okay, well, let's figure out what changed. Let's go back and see what was in the release. And you're like, hey, Joe, did we change this thing? Right? And you start going down because almost always, almost every single time in software if there's a problem it's because something changed right like crap crap just doesn't randomly break like that doesn't really happen you know maybe a server goes down or you know aws there's like a super bowl ad
我不知道发生了什么，但当我们五分钟前进行部署时，突然之间，这个数据库查询变得非常慢。然后这有助于给你一些线索，对吧？比如，“好吧，让我们弄清楚发生了什么变化。让我们回去看看发布版本里有什么。”然后你会说：“嘿，Joe，我们改了这个东西吗？”对吧？然后你开始深入挖掘，因为几乎每次，在软件中，如果出现问题，几乎总是因为某些东西发生了变化，对吧？烂代码不会无缘无故地坏掉，这种情况真的不会发生。你知道，也许服务器宕机了，或者，你知道，AWS 有超级碗广告，
super bowl ad and your server just yeah yeah but usually it's something changed, right? And we have to figure out as fast as possible what changed, right? And that's, you know, going back to kind of where we started the conversation is agile development and, you know, these rapid deployments cause a lot of change, a lot of change events. And that's where all the risk comes from. And I'm a huge fan of doing deployments actually more often because then you're shipping fewer changes at a time, right? You're like, well, we did a deployment, but we only made five changes. So it's like, it was one of the five things. Where if you do a deployment-
超级碗广告，然后你的服务器就……是的，是的，但通常是某些东西发生了变化，对吧？我们必须尽快弄清楚发生了什么变化，对吧？这就是，你知道，回到我们谈话开始的地方，敏捷开发，你知道，这些快速部署导致了大量的变化，大量的变化事件。而这就是所有风险的来源。我非常喜欢更频繁地进行部署，因为这样你每次交付的变更就更少，对吧？你会说：“好吧，我们做了一次部署，但我们只做了五个改动。”所以，这五个改动中的一个出了问题。而如果你进行一次部署——
If you can slow roll it even better, right? So at any given time, you have 10, 20 different deployments at the same time and you can compare and contrast all of them yeah where if you where if you do a deployment and you change 50 things and something doesn't work you're like oh crap where do we start yeah yeah there's no place you know so and i have to confess you know i i've i've never um i haven't done a lot of DevOps. I find those people like SREs to be just total magicians. I think it's amazing, but this already has taught me a lot.
如果你能缓慢滚动发布（slow roll）就更好了，对吧？所以任何时候，你都有 10 到 20 个不同的部署同时进行，你可以比较和对比它们。是的，如果你进行一次部署，改动了 50 个地方，而某些东西不能工作，你会想：“哦，天哪，我们从哪里开始？”是的，是的，没有地方……你知道，我必须承认，你知道，我从来没有……我没有做过很多 DevOps。我觉得那些人，比如 SRE，简直就是魔术师。我认为这很神奇，但这已经教会了我很多。
Can you walk me through the user experience here? So let's say they've set up Stackify, they're logging a ton of stuff. What's the reporting look like? Is it a bunch of graphs? Is it some SQL database where they can write queries? I mean, like, how do people actually triage this? What are they seeing when they do that? Yeah, products like Stackify are a lot of dashboards and reporting. So, you know, a lot of analytical just dashboards and stuff. So you can go in and pick a specific application and then immediately see, okay, how does this thing perform over time?
你能带我了解一下这里的用户体验吗？所以假设他们已经设置了 Stackify，他们正在记录大量的东西。报告看起来是什么样的？是一堆图表吗？是一个他们可以编写查询的 SQL 数据库吗？我的意思是，人们实际上是如何分类处理这些信息的？当他们这样做时，他们看到了什么？是的，像 Stackify 这样的产品有很多仪表板和报告。所以，你知道，很多分析仪表板之类的东西。所以你可以进去选择一个特定的应用程序，然后立即看到，“好吧，这个东西随时间表现如何？”
How much traffic does it get over time, you know, on charts and graphs and stuff? And be able to quickly see, you know, these are my top performing, you know, worst performing things, things that get used the most, all that kind of stuff. So, you know, a lot of things kind of very quickly bubble up to the top. And usually people use products like this in two modes. They're either being very reactive. They're like, okay, we did an employment and the whole building is on fire. Everybody's running around. Everybody's stressed out. We're all not sure if we should just get our resumes up to date and just go find a new job. Or do we fix this thing? Right. And so you're very reactive and you're trying to find the problem.
它随时间的流量是多少，你知道，在图表和图形上？并且能够快速看到，“这些是我的表现最好、表现最差的东西，使用最多的东西，”所有这些事情。所以，你知道，很多东西会非常快地浮出水面。通常人们在两种模式下使用这样的产品。他们要么非常被动。他们会说：“好吧，我们做了一次部署，整栋大楼都着火了。每个人都在跑来跑去。每个人都压力很大。我们都不确定我们是否应该更新简历然后去找一份新工作。还是我们修复这个东西？”对吧。所以你非常被动，试图找到问题。
Right. That's that. And that is one use case for all this kind of stuff. The other side of it is being proactive. It's more of the Boy Scout mode. It's like, OK, how do we improve our software? And this is kind of the role of SRE today of like, okay, we get 30,000 requests per minute. How do we make this thing faster? You know, how do we, you know, make it less fragile? How do we make it so it costs less for us to host? How do we improve our user experience? Like all those sort of things, right? And proactively just trying to figure out these sort of things. And amazingly, when people don't use APM type of products, they don't know what they don't know. It's like Schrodinger's cat. Like, is the cat alive or dead? Is the bug in our software alive or dead? Does it exist or not? We don't know. And maybe we don't want to know but then you install you know products
对。这就是那种情况。这是所有这类东西的一个用例。另一面是主动。这更像是童子军模式。就像，“好吧，我们如何改进我们的软件？”这就是今天 SRE 的角色，比如，“好吧，我们每分钟收到 30,000 个请求。我们如何让这个东西更快？你知道，我们如何让它不那么脆弱？我们如何让它的托管成本更低？我们如何改善我们的用户体验？”所有这些事情，对吧？并主动地试图弄清楚这些事情。令人惊讶的是，当人们不使用 APM 类型的产品时，他们不知道自己不知道什么。这就像薛定谔的猫。猫是活的还是死的？我们软件里的漏洞是活的还是死的？它存在吗？我们不知道。也许我们不想知道，但当你安装了
like this and all of a sudden we you know you start collecting all the errors in the software and you're like holy crap there's like 300 errors on our software being thrown 300 different errors not the same one 300 times but 300 different errors being logged in our software every hour you're like oh my god we got some crappy code that's doing some dumb things. Null reference exceptions everywhere. Just like, oh my God. And it's like Schrodinger's cat kind of thing. Like you don't know what you don't know until you know.
像这样的产品，突然之间，你开始收集软件中的所有错误，你会想：“天哪，我们的软件里有 300 个错误。”不是同一个错误出现了 300 次，而是每小时在我们的软件中记录了 300 个不同的错误。你会想：“哦，天哪，我们有一些烂代码在做一些愚蠢的事情。”到处都是空引用异常。就像，“哦，天哪。”这就像薛定谔的猫。在你真正知道之前，你不知道自己不知道什么。
And then you sort of don't want to know. Yeah, you find out. Yeah, I think it's so true, y'all. When I'm writing code, especially as I've gotten more experienced, I'll put logs, I'll be much more diligent about writing logs. And, you know, I'll get to a point where I'll say, you know, oh, you'll never actually get here. And I'll just put a log saying, you know, we'll never get here.
然后你其实并不想知道。是的，你发现了。是的，我觉得这太真实了，各位。当我写代码时，尤其是随着经验的增加，我会加入日志，在编写日志方面会勤奋得多。而且，你知道，我会写到某个地方说，你知道，你永远不会真的走到这里。然后我就会放一个日志说，你知道，我们永远不会走到这里。
And then, you know, a year later, you go and look at the code or people send you the traces. And it's always like, should never get here here i don't remember why this should be three and then colon two right i mean it's just like and it's just terrifying and see at your point it's kind of you know you build up and then people leave the team too right and so that intellectual capital is gone right and so uh definitely you know bite that bullet as soon as possible um otherwise it just gets so hard to go back and recover. Well, and I have a particular saying that I'm very fond of that I think every developer should have tattooed right on their forehead.
然后，你知道，一年后，你去查看代码，或者人们把追踪记录发给你。总是像这样，永远不该到这里，我不记得为什么这里应该是3，然后冒号2，对吧？我的意思是，这简直太可怕了。回到你的观点，这就像是你建立了一些东西，然后人们也离开了团队，对吧？所以那些智力资本就消失了，对吧？所以，嗯，绝对要尽快咬牙解决它，否则回头去修复它会变得非常困难。嗯，我有一句特别喜欢的格言，我认为每个开发人员都应该把它纹在额头上。
And it is, if it can be null, it will be null. Yeah, that's so true. Okay? And it goes back to the point of you just mentioned, like, this thing shouldn't happen, but it could. Yeah, yeah. And then what do we do if it if it does happen right and same thing with things being null like everybody thinks code is perfectly
那就是，如果它可能是空的，它最终就会是空的。是的，这太真实了。对吧？这回到了你刚才提到的观点，比如，这件事不应该发生，但它确实可能发生。是的，是的。然后如果它真的发生了，我们该怎么办？对于为空的情况也是一样，每个人都认为代码是完美的
magical and there's like puppies and clouds and rainbows but one in a thousand times there's not and what's great about software is if it works 99.99 of the time it works perfectly right that means like one in 10 000000 times it fails miserably. And that's perfectly acceptable. We live in this world where like one in 10,000 airplanes could fall out of a sky and it's okay. That's software development for you, right? And that's the reality of software too, is there are problems all the time that you do not anticipate you cannot anticipate but you have to try you always have to be defensive in your programming to your point earlier like we add this logging in here just in case this weird scenario happens or something is null that we
充满魔力的，就像有小狗、云朵和彩虹一样，但一千次里总有一次不是这样。软件的伟大之处在于，如果它99.99%的时间都能正常工作，那它就是完美的，对吧？这意味着一千万次里有一次会惨败。这完全是可以接受的。我们生活在这样一个世界里，一万架飞机里可能有一架会掉下来，这也没关系。这就是软件开发，对吧？这也是软件的现实，总会有你无法预料、也无法防范的问题，但你必须尝试，你必须始终在编程中保持防御性。回到你刚才的观点，我们加入这些日志就是为了以防万一出现这种奇怪的情况，或者某些我们
didn't expect to be null but you have to account for it because if it can be it will happen it and it happens every time you had to give a first- example, I mean, you know, we rolled out, I rolled out the Eternal Terminal, which is this SSH alternative. And one thing I didn't expect was people running out of memory. Because, you know, I'm looking at my desktop here, I have 64 gigs of RAM, my laptop has probably the same. And I didn't really think about, you know, Eternal Terminal uses maybe 50 megs, right? But someone out there was running it on a VM that
没预料到会为空的东西变成了空值，但你必须考虑到这一点，因为如果它可能发生，它就一定会发生。而且每次都会发生。我举个例子，你知道，我们推出了 Eternal Terminal，这是一个 SSH 的替代品。我没预料到的一件事是人们会耗尽内存。因为，你知道，我看着我的台式机，我有 64G 内存，我的笔记本电脑可能也差不多。我真的没想过，你知道，Eternal Terminal 可能只占用 50 兆内存，对吧？但有人在虚拟机上运行它，
they got for free. And yeah, just all things started breaking all over the place. And it's because every time you ask for memory, you could end up not getting it. Yeah. You know, what am I? Yeah. It's just that stuff ends up being really difficult to do after the fact. You know, and you're adding to that topic. We never think about performance these days because computers are fast and we have fast internet, right? But what happens when you're working on an airplane that's flying over the Pacific Ocean
那是他们免费得到的。然后，是的，所有东西都开始到处崩溃。这是因为每次你申请内存时，你最终都可能得不到它。是的。你知道，我是什么？是的。这些事情事后处理起来真的非常困难。你知道，补充一下这个话题。我们现在从不考虑性能，因为计算机很快，我们有很快的互联网，对吧？但当你在一架飞越太平洋的飞机上工作时会发生什么？
that has the worst Wi-Fi connection in the entire world, and you're trying to use a website, right? You're trying to surf the web or do something, and it's like the slowest thing in the world. But as developers, we don't think about those scenarios. It's all those sort of scenarios that we never think about that then cause all sorts of errors and bad user experience. Yeah, and that's where I think tools like Stackify are really important because they give you a window into the entire user base. And there is that needle in the haystack, which we talked about earlier, and that seems pretty overwhelming. But with the right tools and the right logging, you can actually find that person who maybe right now is flying over the Pacific using your app.
那里的 Wi-Fi 连接是世界上最差的，而你正试图使用一个网站，对吧？你试图上网或做点什么，结果它是世界上最慢的东西。但作为开发人员，我们不会考虑这些场景。正是所有这些我们从未考虑过的场景，导致了各种错误和糟糕的用户体验。是的，这就是我认为像 Stackify 这样的工具非常重要的原因，因为它们为你提供了一个观察整个用户群的窗口。而且正如我们之前提到的，大海捞针的情况确实存在，这看起来相当令人不知所措。但有了正确的工具和正确的日志记录，你实际上可以找到那个可能此刻正飞越太平洋并使用你的应用程序的人。
Well, you mentioned your logging. Logging is really important, but it's even more important to do the right type of logging and using logging levels. So it's like that weird scenario you mentioned, that needs to be logged at a warning or error or fatal level, right? Not a debug level. And that's where when people's apps get deployed to production, a lot of times debug logs and stuff aren't turned on because they can be like a crazy volume of information. But you need to look for things that are warnings or error or fatal
嗯，你提到了你的日志记录。日志记录非常重要，但进行正确类型的日志记录并使用日志级别更为重要。所以就像你提到的那种奇怪的情况，它需要被记录为警告、错误或致命级别，对吧？而不是调试级别。这就是为什么当人们的应用程序部署到生产环境时，很多时候调试日志之类的东西没有开启，因为它们可能会产生海量的信息。但你需要寻找那些警告、错误或致命的
and those types of severity. And then it makes it easy to log into a tool like Stackify and say, okay, let's look at all the logs that are warning or fatal or whatever and go find those problems. Yeah, that totally makes sense. What about, how do you handle machines that are misbehaving? So in this case, if you look at the overall data, it might be fine. But I remember an issue that we had a number of years ago where basically our app was creating new threads. And so it was just constantly creating new threads. And at some point, the machine would die.
以及这些严重程度的日志。然后，登录像 Stackify 这样的工具并说，好吧，让我们查看所有警告或致命等日志，并去找出那些问题，就变得很容易了。是的，这完全说得通。那么，你如何处理行为异常的机器呢？在这种情况下，如果你查看整体数据，它可能看起来没问题。但我记得几年前我们遇到的一个问题，基本上我们的应用程序在不断创建新线程。所以它一直在创建新线程。在某个时刻，机器就会死掉。
And AWS or whatever the cloud we were using would just kill that machine based on some logic they had. And then it would spin another one up. And so it's one of these things that we actually, it took us a long time to even know something was wrong, because you can't really tell. But if you were to look at a single machine, you could see that things were getting kind of bad, right? And so how do you handle that? We have this sort of heterogeneous environment where some machines are healthy, some aren't? I had this exact type of issue happen this week at Stackify.
然后 AWS 或我们使用的任何云服务就会根据它们拥有的某种逻辑杀掉那台机器。然后它会再启动一台。所以这是我们实际上遇到的事情之一，我们花了很长时间才知道出了问题，因为你真的看不出来。但如果你查看单台机器，你会发现情况变得有点糟糕，对吧？那么你如何处理这个问题呢？我们有这种异构环境，有些机器健康，有些不健康？我这周在 Stackify 就遇到了这种类型的问题。
We deployed a new application on Kubernetes in our QA environment. For whatever reason, the pod would fail, and then Kubernetes would restart the pod and create a new one. Except the problem is it did it 7,000 times over like three days. And then Kubernetes ran out of memory. Oh, okay. The node in the cluster like ran out of memory. Now, luckily this was in QA and it wasn't a big deal. But these things happen to your point,
我们在 Kubernetes 的 QA 环境中部署了一个新的应用程序。不管什么原因，Pod 会失败，然后 Kubernetes 会重启 Pod 并创建一个新的。问题是它在三天内重复了 7000 次。然后 Kubernetes 内存耗尽了。哦，好吧。集群中的节点内存耗尽了。幸运的是，这在 QA 环境中，不是什么大问题。但正如你所说，这些事情会发生，
like things that you don't anticipate. And actually the fix for that was we had just put memory limits on the pod and then it behaved just fine. Like just really weird stuff. And to your point, like these are problems that still happen. We've got another app in Stackify that's actually in production for us. And the only way we can make the thing work is to restart it every 30 minutes. Oh no, that's so brutal.
就像那些你无法预料的事情。实际上，解决办法就是我们给 Pod 设置了内存限制，然后它就表现得很好了。就像一些非常奇怪的事情。而且正如你所说，这些问题仍然会发生。我们在 Stackify 中有另一个应用程序，实际上是在生产环境中运行的。我们让它工作的唯一方法是每 30 分钟重启一次。哦，不，这太残酷了。
But these things happen, right? And you're like, okay, do we spend like millions of man hours and dollars fixing this thing? Or do we make a script to restart it every 30 minutes? Yeah, yeah. That is a really good point, right? Especially when we dive into this, it's easy to kind of say, well, we'll log everything. We will do a deployment once a year or something like that. But there's always these trade-offs, right? And so, you know, it could be that if your business
但这些事情确实会发生，对吧？你会想，好吧，我们是花数百万工时和美元来修复这个东西呢？还是写个脚本每 30 分钟重启一次？是的，是的。这确实是一个很好的观点，对吧？特别是当我们深入研究这个问题时，很容易说，好吧，我们会记录一切。我们会一年部署一次之类的。但总是有这些权衡，对吧？所以，你知道，可能是如果你的业务
doesn't move fast enough, like if you're not pivoting based on the user experience fast enough, that you fail at the business level. And so you're kind of running up against that. You have to kind of balance. This is one of the things that I think a good tech lead will do well, is balance sort of moving fast or maybe being sort of more interactive with the other cross-functional teams. Balance that against accumulating all this technical debt. And so I think that requires constant supervision. Well, and we could record a whole podcast episode
发展不够快，比如如果你没有根据用户体验足够快地进行调整，你就会在业务层面失败。所以你有点在对抗这一点。你必须进行平衡。我认为一个好的技术主管会做得很好的一件事，就是平衡快速前进或者可能与其他跨职能团队进行更多互动。平衡这一点与积累所有这些技术债务。所以我认为这需要持续的监督。嗯，我们可以录制一整集播客
just on this topic. But the problem is software developers always chase shiny objects, right? They're like, hey, we want to rewrite everything in Kubernetes because why not? And so we redo everything with Kubernetes and then like a year later, they're like, nah, let's move
专门讨论这个话题。但问题是软件开发人员总是追逐闪亮的新事物，对吧？他们会说，嘿，我们想用 Kubernetes 重写一切，因为为什么不呢？所以我们用 Kubernetes 重做了一切，然后一年后，他们说，不，让我们迁移
to aws lambda that's even cooler now and it'll look better on our resume so then it's like let's just spend the next no we're literally not going to ship a new feature we're too busy we're moving everything to kubernetes and lambda right like that's what like people do this and then they never deliver new functionality to their customers you're absolutely right like i could go on this topic for like an hour yeah yeah i know i have a friend who works in the games industry and he says, you know, I asked him really to describe what this crunch phenomenon was. This was around the time when, you know, there was a lot of publicity around the crunch hours that game developers work and things like that. And, you know, he basically explained to me really well. He said
到 AWS Lambda，现在那更酷，而且在我们的简历上看起来更好。所以接下来就像是，让我们花接下来的时间，不，我们实际上不会发布任何新功能，我们太忙了，我们正在把一切迁移到 Kubernetes 和 Lambda，对吧？就像人们这样做，然后他们永远不会向客户交付新功能。你是绝对正确的，我可以就这个话题讲上一个小时。是的，是的，我知道。我有一个在游戏行业工作的朋友，他说，你知道，我真的问他描述一下这种“紧迫期”（crunch）现象是什么。这大约是在那个时候，你知道，关于游戏开发人员工作的紧迫时间等等有很多宣传。而且，你知道，他基本上向我解释得很好。他说
it's basically feature creep, except because a game is kind of this atomic thing where you just release the game, it's all hypothetical, right? So the game designer will come to the engineers and say, oh, we need to add a 14th lineman in Madden. Otherwise, no one will play this game. And then they go and they code it up. It's like, oh, now the football needs to be orange.
这基本上就是功能蔓延（feature creep），只不过因为游戏是一种原子化的东西，你只是发布游戏，这一切都是假设的，对吧？所以游戏设计师会来到工程师面前说，哦，我们需要在《Madden》中增加第 14 个边锋。否则没人会玩这个游戏。然后他们去编写代码。就像，哦，现在橄榄球需要是橙色的。
It has to be orange. Everyone loves orange. And then, oh, now we want the person to be able to set the color, right? And so you get all of these changing requirements and you're working these insane hours. And so then that's one of the reasons why I think code quality on games
它必须是橙色的。每个人都喜欢橙色。然后，哦，现在我们希望玩家能够设置颜色，对吧？所以你得到了所有这些不断变化的需求，你正在工作这些疯狂的时间。所以这就是我认为游戏代码质量
has always been a challenge. Yeah, feature creep is a never-ending problem in software development just and and to some sense developers are our own worst enemy on it too where you know i'm talking to one of my team members this week and and we use like a sql parser that parses sql statements and we're having problems with it and i'm like okay well if and we use like a third-party product to do this. If it doesn't work, we have some fallback logic. We'll just have this little regular expressions that are fallback logic. My developer's like, no, we need to write our own SQL parser.
一直是一个挑战的原因之一。是的，功能蔓延是软件开发中一个永无止境的问题，而且在某种意义上，开发人员也是自己最大的敌人。比如我这周在和我的团队成员交谈，我们使用一个 SQL 解析器来解析 SQL 语句，我们遇到了问题，我说，好吧，如果我们使用第三方产品来做这个。如果它不起作用，我们有一些回退逻辑。我们会有这些小的正则表达式作为回退逻辑。我的开发人员说，不，我们需要编写我们自己的 SQL 解析器。
I'm like, no, we don't. We really don't need to do that. We have other stuff to do. That's what developers do. People love building stuff yeah that's where our own worst enemy of you know what i always say like doing software development sideways like we're not moving forward to like really improve our product and deliver new stuff to our customers we're just like moving sideways okay you know i wanted to piggyback on that so
我说，不，我们不需要。我们真的不需要那样做。我们还有其他事情要做。这就是开发人员所做的。人们喜欢构建东西。是的，这就是我们自己最大的敌人，你知道我总是说，像横向进行软件开发，我们没有向前推进以真正改进我们的产品并向客户交付新东西，我们只是在横向移动。好吧，你知道，我想顺着这个话题说，
you make a product for developers you know when started Stackify, were you afraid of that? Because that's one thing that I've always wondered. And we talked to a lot of folks who make, you know, for whom developers are the end user. And, you know, one of the fears is that you can provide 99 percent of the functionality. And then the developer says, no, I want to I want to build my own Stackify for my own company. Right. And so how do you defend yourself against that? I mean, there's really nothing you can do. At some point in time, you just have to say no. And we, you know, this is actually something I have to remind our teams all the time. Like our customers will come to us and like, oh, Stackify doesn't work in this like purple squirrel mode. And we're like, nope, sorry. Yep, it doesn't. And we're not going
你为开发人员制作产品，你知道，当开始 Stackify 时，你害怕那个吗？因为这是我一直想知道的一件事。我们和很多为开发人员提供服务的人交谈，对他们来说开发人员是最终用户。而且，你知道，恐惧之一是你提供了 99% 的功能。然后开发人员说，不，我想为我自己的公司构建我自己的 Stackify。对吧。所以你如何防御这一点？我的意思是，真的没有什么你能做的。在某个时间点，你只需要说不。而且我们，你知道，这实际上是我必须一直提醒我们团队的事情。比如我们的客户会来到我们这里，说，哦，Stackify 在这种“紫松鼠模式”下不起作用。我们说，不，抱歉。是的，它不起作用。而且我们不会
to fix it because our other 99% of our customers don't care about that. And we're not going to bet our entire company on that 1%. Like the other 99%, we have got to service, right? And we've got to make an incredible product for that 99%. Yeah. When you started Stackify, how did you know that these people would use it and not try and build their own thing? Well, I Yeah, when you started Stackify, how did you know that these people would use it and not try and build their own thing? Well, I mean, when we first started out, what we were doing was a little different, right? And I think maybe developers these days, compared to maybe, say, 10 or 15 years ago, are maybe a little more over of the, like, I'm going to build my own version of this.
去修复它，因为我们其他 99% 的客户并不关心那个。我们不会把整个公司押在那 1% 上。那 99%，我们必须服务好，对吧？我们必须为那 99% 制作一个令人难以置信的产品。是的。当你开始 Stackify 时，你怎么知道这些人会使用它而不是尝试构建他们自己的东西？嗯，我，是的，当你开始 Stackify 时，你怎么知道这些人会使用它而不是尝试构建他们自己的东西？嗯，我，我的意思是，当我们刚开始时，我们所做的事情有点不同，对吧？而且我认为也许现在的开发人员，与 10 或 15 年前相比，可能对“我要构建我自己的这个版本”这种想法稍微多了一点点。
I mean, I think that was definitely the case like 15 or 20 years ago. You're like, oh, we need some little JavaScript library or some little library that does this or does that. And yeah, developers were really bad about it. Like, oh, I'm just going to create one instead of buying one for $400. And maybe because things now, there's so many SaaS products,
我的意思是，我认为 15 或 20 年前绝对是这种情况。你会说，哦，我们需要一些小的 JavaScript 库或一些做这个或那个的小库。而且是的，开发人员在这方面真的很糟糕。比如，哦，我只是要创建一个，而不是花 400 美元买一个。也许是因为现在有很多 SaaS 产品，
there's no way. If somebody wants to rebuild Stackify, good luck, and I'll talk to you in five years. It's so complicated. I was like, good luck. It's not like some little JavaScript library that does this one cute thing like change currencies
没门。如果有人想重建 Stackify，祝你好运，五年后再聊。这太复杂了。我当时想，祝你好运。这不像是一些做这种可爱小事的小 JavaScript 库，比如更改货币
or time zones or something. Maybe that's the difference right like so many sass products like you want to create your own version of twilio or send grid like good luck go for it if you want to master that go for it it just doesn't make any sense it'll take you five years to make emails that don't go to spam yeah good alone and and to be honest with you that's the most amazing thing about being a developer these days is we have Azure and AWS and all these different platform as a service stuff and APIs that we can use for things like Twilio and SendGrid or machine learning or a thousand other things that just make it so much easier to build software and not have to reinvent all of those wheels. Writing software today is so much easier because of all of those things, but then it's so much more difficult for other reasons. Yeah, I think people just are much more productive. And then because of that, I think it's much more lean. You could have three people do an entire. There's this, I can't remember the name of it, but there is this social network that's kind of like a TikTok thing, but it's audio only. I can't remember the name off the top of my head it's just it's just three people and they were saying they don't even really have any incentive to hire a bunch of people because uh it's already you know they've scaled it up themselves yeah so yeah so let's talk about um let's talk about stackify uh you know
或时区之类的。也许这就是区别，对吧？这么多 SaaS 产品，你想创建自己的 Twilio 或 SendGrid 版本，祝你好运，如果你想掌握它，那就去做吧。这根本没有意义，你需要五年时间才能做出不会进入垃圾邮件的电子邮件。是的，祝你好运。而且老实说，作为一名开发人员，这些天最令人惊奇的事情是我们有 Azure 和 AWS 以及所有这些不同的平台即服务的东西和 API，我们可以用于像 Twilio 和 SendGrid 或机器学习或成千上万的其他事情，这使得构建软件变得容易得多，而不必重新发明所有这些轮子。今天编写软件因为所有这些东西而变得容易得多，但由于其他原因，它也变得更加困难。是的，我认为人们只是效率高得多。而且因为这样，我认为它更精简。你可以让三个人完成整个。有一个，我不记得它的名字了，但有一个社交网络，有点像 TikTok，但它是纯音频的。我不记得名字了，它只有三个人，他们说他们甚至真的没有任何动力去雇佣一大群人，因为嗯，它已经，你知道，他们自己已经扩展了它。是的，所以，让我们谈谈嗯，让我们谈谈 Stackify，你知道
what is the you know company like in terms of where do folks work is it sort of distributed you have a lot of folks here in college that are looking around for internship opportunities. Do y'all do internships? Do you do? Are you hiring full time? Kind of like walk us through the company, maybe even like what a day is like working at Stackify. Yeah, so we have about 45 to 50 employees and about half of about 25 of those are in the Kansas City area. And then we have about 20 employees in the Philippines. So we have a lot of our engineering is done in the Philippines. And then we do customer support as well. And some other things out of the Philippines. And part of that is because Stackify is a global company. We have customers in 60 countries.
公司在员工工作地点方面是什么样的？它是分布式的吗？你们在大学里有很多寻找实习机会的人吗？你们做实习吗？你们在全职招聘吗？带我们了解一下公司，也许甚至像在 Stackify 工作的一天是什么样的。是的，所以我们大约有 45 到 50 名员工，其中大约一半，大约 25 人在堪萨斯城地区。然后我们在菲律宾有大约 20 名员工。所以我们很多工程工作是在菲律宾完成的。然后我们也从菲律宾做客户支持以及其他一些事情。部分原因是 Stackify 是一家全球性公司。我们在 60 个国家有客户。
And so we have to operate 24 hours a day. So we have support people and developers, 14 time zones different on purpose. Wow, that's wild. So we can help support our customers globally. But at Stackify in Kansas City, we hire a lot of entry level developers to do support because our product is so technical. So we actually hire developers to do like customer service, customer support. It's like really high level kind of technical support
所以我们必须 24 小时运作。所以我们有支持人员和开发人员，特意安排在 14 个时区。哇，那太疯狂了。所以我们可以帮助在全球范围内支持我们的客户。但在堪萨斯城的 Stackify，我们雇佣很多入门级开发人员来做支持，因为我们的产品太技术化了。所以我们实际上雇佣开发人员来做类似客户服务、客户支持的工作。这就像是非常高水平的技术支持
for our customers. And then a lot of times those developers then work their way potentially into our engineering team. And so I think that's a great career path for developers is to work in that kind of like tier two, tier three kind of customer service and high tech companies, learn the product, have like really invaluable product knowledge that way and then be able to bring that product knowledge and customer kind of viewpoint right into the engineering team and then continue to grow their their engineering skills i think that's a great career path and we had a developer at vin solutions that did that at my old company came in as entry level
为我们的客户。然后很多时候这些开发人员随后会进入我们的工程团队。所以我认为这对开发人员来说是一条很好的职业道路，在那种二级、三级客户服务和高科技公司工作，了解产品，以那种方式拥有非常宝贵的产品知识，然后能够将那种产品知识和客户观点带入工程团队，并继续发展他们的工程技能。我认为这是一条很好的职业道路，我们在 Vin Solutions 有一个开发人员就是这样做的，在我以前的公司，他作为入门级
support worked his way up through all the support, became an engineer on the team, and then left and founded his own software company. Now he has his own software company he started. And so I think that's a great career path for people. Yeah, that makes sense. So the folks in the field, like how do you deal with 14 times? We have trouble. I'm two time zones away from my boss and and we have trouble with our team how do you deal with 14 time zone difference um so we have some people that work
支持人员进来，通过所有的支持工作，成为了团队中的一名工程师，然后离开并创立了自己的软件公司。现在他有了自己创立的软件公司。所以我认为这对人们来说是一条很好的职业道路。是的，这说得通。那么在现场的人，你们如何处理 14 个时区？我们有麻烦。我离我的老板有两个时区，我们团队就有麻烦，你们如何处理 14 个时区的差异？嗯，所以我们有一些人工作
um our hours in kansas kansas city hours so that's full they work like the graveyard shift there like overnight shift there but most of them actually work there like 3 p.m to midnight their time which overlaps to like 11 in the morning uh kansas city time so you know we have meetings and stuff like that with them and them in the mornings and um then how do you keep the how do you keep the cadence up right so let's say you meet once a day um you know i've seen issues where i need these are people who are only 100 yards apart. Right. But they'll send an email. The person will respond the next day.
嗯，我们的时间，堪萨斯城时间，所以那是全职，他们在那里上夜班，类似通宵班，但他们大多数人实际上是在那里工作，比如下午 3 点到午夜，这与堪萨斯城时间的上午 11 点重叠。所以你知道，我们在早上和他们开会之类的。然后你如何保持节奏，对吧？假设你每天见一次面，你知道，我见过一些问题，这些人只相隔 100 码。对吧。但他们会发电子邮件。那个人第二天才会回复。
They'll respond the next day. And it's just nothing's getting done. And you finally have to say, OK, you know, we need to just sit together. And I found that to be a recurring problem. How do you how do you handle you know, how do you close that loop? I think those are all communication and management problems. Right. And, you know, that's the great thing about Slack and things like that, being able to communicate with people instantly and get work done and collaborate.
他们第二天才会回复。什么都没做成。你最终不得不说，好吧，你知道，我们需要坐在一起。我发现这是一个反复出现的问题。你如何处理，你知道，你如何闭环？我认为这些都是沟通和管理问题。对吧。而且，你知道，这就是 Slack 之类东西的伟大之处，能够立即与人沟通并完成工作并进行协作。
And a lot of the challenges that you mentioned are totally different now that everybody's working remote. And working remote, I don't know about you guys, if you've ever worked remote or been on a team that was partially remote, but I think the worst case scenario is you've got five or six people on a team that work together and then you have one person who works remote. Right. Like that one person is always in the dark and they will never know anything. Right. Because the other five or six people are in one room and when one of them breathes weird, everybody knows what they're thinking. Because, you know, there's that osmosis of just that teamwork, right? And being together and just knowing the personalities of people and all that sort of stuff. But now that we're all
而且你提到的很多挑战现在完全不同了，因为每个人都在远程工作。远程工作，我不知道你们，如果你们曾经远程工作或在部分远程的团队中工作过，但我认为最坏的情况是团队中有五六个人在一起工作，然后有一个人远程工作。对吧。那个人总是处于黑暗中，他们永远不会知道任何事情。对吧。因为其他五六个人在一个房间里，当其中一个人呼吸奇怪时，每个人都知道他们在想什么。因为，你知道，那种团队合作的渗透，对吧？在一起，了解人们的个性等等。但现在我们都在
working remote, all of that has gone away. Like the communication style has to change dramatically. And now that one person in my example before that was the odd the odd person out that was always in the dark now all of a sudden it's a level playing field like everybody has to communicate in a different way and the big thing that people have to strive for is just the sense of urgency it's like yeah i need so-and-so's help to figure this out i could email them and just pray that they respond eventually, or I could call their butt right now and get a damn answer and figure this out. And what I always used to say when we're all in the office is I'm like,
远程工作，所有这些都消失了。沟通方式必须发生巨大变化。现在我之前例子中那个总是被排除在外、总是处于黑暗中的人，现在突然间变成了一个公平的竞争环境，每个人都必须以不同的方式沟通，人们必须努力争取的大事就是紧迫感。就像，是的，我需要某人的帮助来弄清楚这一点。我可以给他们发电子邮件并祈祷他们最终回复，或者我可以现在就打电话给他们，得到一个该死的答案并弄清楚这一点。我以前在办公室时总是说，
go sit on their desk until you figure it out. Like go figure it out now. Yeah, I feel like that. That sense of urgency is the key. Yeah, I feel like what I've noticed noticed and I've noticed this in myself too, is sometimes you could end up like subconsciously procrastinating where it's like, you know,
去坐在他们的桌子旁，直到你弄清楚为止。现在就去弄清楚。是的，我觉得那样。那种紧迫感是关键。是的，我觉得我注意到的，我自己也注意到了，有时你可能会潜意识地拖延，就像，你知道，
it's a big deal. It's not even really procrastinating. It's subconsciously not unblocking yourself. So you're kind of, you hit this roadblock and you don't even really know it's a roadblock. Like maybe it's some technical problem that you don't know how to solve. Or maybe it's a person that you need to talk to, but you don't quite know who to talk to. And so you just end up paralyzed.
这是一件大事。这甚至不是真正的拖延。这是潜意识里没有解除自己的阻塞。所以你有点，你遇到了这个障碍，你甚至不知道它是一个障碍。也许是一些你不知道如何解决的技术问题。或者也许是你需要交谈的人，但你不太知道该找谁谈。所以你最终瘫痪了。
And if you ask somebody like, hey, what's the status on this? They'll say, oh, I'm working on it. And then at some point you kind of realize, oh, no, this is actually blocked. And there's sort of like state of like unconscious, uh, misunderstanding. Right. And, uh, yeah, I think, I think actually to your point, being online might actually make that easier. Um, because when you're, when you're in person, you might see the person kind of stressed and say, oh, this person must be working really hard.
如果你问某人，嘿，这个的状态是什么？他们会说，哦，我正在处理。然后你在某个时刻意识到，哦，不，这实际上是被阻塞了。这有点像是一种无意识的误解状态。对吧。而且，嗯，我认为实际上正如你所说，在线可能实际上让这更容易。嗯，因为当你面对面时，你可能会看到那个人有点压力，说，哦，这个人一定工作得很努力。
Right. Or I can tell I need some help. Running into a wall. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, I think there's always a delicate balance to this, right? Because you don't want to be bothering people all day long and asking them dumb questions that you can answer on Stack Overflow. But at the same time, you don't want to sit there and be marinating on problems and not getting anything accomplished because you're not asking for help. There's definitely a very delicate balance there. And it's always a struggle.
对吧。或者我可以看出我需要一些帮助。撞到墙上了。是的，是的。是的，我认为这总是一个微妙的平衡，对吧？因为你不想整天打扰别人，问他们可以在 Stack Overflow 上回答的愚蠢问题。但同时，你也不想坐在那里，在问题上纠结，却因为不寻求帮助而一事无成。这绝对是一个非常微妙的平衡。而且这总是一个挣扎。
And, you know, I always tell my developers on my team that it's like, you know, if you need help, ask. I'd rather you ask for help and be overly annoying about it than be sitting there wasting a bunch of time. And I think, you know, these things are the reason we have standups and different things like that on a daily basis is not necessarily because we need them, because if you had the right people that are good at communication, they would ask the questions. But it's almost like we have standup every day because some people aren't very good at
而且，你知道，我总是告诉我的团队开发人员，就像，你知道，如果你需要帮助，就问。我宁愿你寻求帮助并对此过于烦人，也不愿你坐在那里浪费大量时间。而且我认为，你知道，这些事情是我们每天进行站会和各种类似事情的原因，不一定是因为我们需要它们，因为如果你有擅长沟通的合适人选，他们会问这些问题。但这几乎就像我们每天都有站会，因为有些人不太擅长
communication. And it's the only it's that chance to say, hey, do you need help? Because otherwise they won't ask for help. And otherwise, you know, if you have all the right people on your team, standups maybe are completely useless. But for some personalities, it's that daily check-in that you need to push that to make sure that, you know, those questions are being asked. Yeah. So on the product side, if someone, again, let's say a college student or someone just getting into programming wants to use Stackify. What is that? I mean, I understand that Stackify is like mostly for enterprise, right? But for folks who want to get started, what is the sort of tier look like? Is there a free tier? What's the environment like for someone who is just an academic trying to get into this area? Great question. And I've got a perfect answer for you.
沟通。这是唯一的机会说，嘿，你需要帮助吗？因为否则他们不会寻求帮助。而且否则，你知道，如果你的团队里有所有合适的人，站会可能完全没用。但对于某些个性来说，这是你需要的每日签到，以推动确保，你知道，那些问题被问出来。是的。那么在产品方面，如果有人，再次假设是一个大学生或刚开始编程的人想要使用 Stackify。那是什么？我的意思是，我明白 Stackify 主要是针对企业的，对吧？但对于想要入门的人，层级看起来是什么样的？有免费层级吗？对于一个只是想进入这个领域的学术人员来说，环境是什么样的？好问题。我有一个完美的答案给你。
So actually, Retrace, our flagship product, our APM product, Retrace, starts at $99 a month. So it's very affordable. It's not like a really expensive enterprise product. We have another tool called Prefix, which is free. And so I honestly think it's the type of tool that you talk about in an educational perspective. It's very, very useful in an educational perspective.
所以实际上，Retrace，我们的旗舰产品，我们的 APM 产品，Retrace，起价为每月 99 美元。所以它非常实惠。它不像一个非常昂贵的企业产品。我们有另一个名为 Prefix 的工具，它是免费的。所以我真心认为它是你从教育角度谈论的那种工具。它在教育角度非常、非常有价值。
And we have some colleges and stuff like that that use it. It's a profiler basically that runs on the developer's laptop. So as you're writing and testing your code, you can instantly see what that code just did. So it'll show you, okay, this page loaded, this transaction loaded, it ran this database query, it did this web service call, it did three more database queries, and here's how long it took,
而且我们有一些大学之类的使用它。它基本上是一个运行在开发人员笔记本电脑上的分析器。所以当你编写和测试代码时，你可以立即看到那段代码刚刚做了什么。所以它会向你展示，好吧，这个页面加载了，这个事务加载了，它运行了这个数据库查询，它进行了这个 Web 服务调用，它又进行了三次数据库查询，这是它花费的时间，
and show you your log messages and everything. So it kind of gives you instant feedback to what did my code just do and did it work? How long did it take? All those sort of things. And then that's a free tool that Stackify provides. It's called Prefix, and I definitely recommend it. Got it. So the idea is someone's just getting started. They probably don't know about Docker and all of this yet. They're SSHed into some AWS box and they are developing some website or something like that. They run prefix. Is it hooked into VS Code or where does prefix actually live?
并向你展示你的日志消息和一切。所以它有点像给你即时反馈，我的代码刚刚做了什么，它起作用了吗？它花了多长时间？所有这些事情。然后那是 Stackify 提供的免费工具。它叫 Prefix，我绝对推荐它。明白了。所以想法是有人刚开始。他们可能还不知道 Docker 和所有这些。他们 SSH 到某个 AWS 盒子，他们正在开发某个网站之类的。他们运行 Prefix。它是挂钩到 VS Code 还是 Prefix 实际上住在哪里？
So usually it's used on your laptop itself, like not on a server. It's on your workstation. Oh, I see. And it's installed the same kind of way that retraces so let's say you're using python you would install our our package into your app and then that would enable the the monkey patching and the profiling that we kind of mentioned earlier and then um prefix will collect that data all locally and just show it to you all locally it doesn't oh got it i see it doesn't connect to the internet or any of that it's all local yeah you're testing locally you have like a local database or using sqlite or something simple and and you're running the same thing you'd run in production but in this test environment and while
所以通常它是在你自己的笔记本电脑上使用的，而不是在服务器上。它在你的工作站上。哦，我明白了。而且它的安装方式和 Retrace 一样，所以假设你正在使用 Python，你会把我们的包安装到你的应用程序中，然后这将启用我们之前提到的猴子补丁和分析，然后嗯，Prefix 将在本地收集所有这些数据，并只在本地向你展示。它不，哦，明白了，我明白了，它不连接到互联网或任何东西，它全是本地的。是的，你在本地测试，你有类似本地数据库或使用 SQLite 或类似简单的东西，而且你运行的是你在生产环境中运行的相同东西，但在测试环境中，当
you're doing that retrace is telling you like oh you're really hammering the sql server right now you don't want to take another look at what you just wrote yeah and that's what that's what prefix does that's why we call it pre fix oh prefix all right that's clever so cool yeah that makes sense that's awesome so everyone out there check it out totally free um i guess it runs on everything like windows mac linux so as of today uh prefix is primarily been for dotnet on Windows but we're getting ready to release a new version that will support six programming languages and also run on the Mac so look for that very soon very cool yeah keep keep your eyes peeled for that also you have a podcast of your own which is which is really cool totally gonna check out. Why don't you give us
你这样做时，Retrace 会告诉你，哦，你现在真的在猛烈攻击 SQL Server，你不想再看看你刚才写的东西吗？是的，这就是 Prefix 所做的，这就是为什么我们叫它 Pre fix。哦，Prefix，好的，这很聪明。太酷了。是的，这说得通，太棒了。所以大家去看看吧，完全免费。嗯，我想它可以在所有东西上运行，比如 Windows、 Mac、 Linux。所以截至今天，嗯，Prefix 主要用于 Windows 上的 .NET，但我们正准备发布一个新版本，它将支持六种编程语言，也可以在 Mac 上运行，所以很快就会看到。太酷了。是的，保持关注。此外，你也有自己的播客，这真的很酷，我绝对会去看看。为什么不给我们
some details about the Startup Hustle and what that's all about? Yeah, so it's called the Startup Hustle and you can find it on Apple and all the places you would find a normal podcast. And it's about entrepreneurship and startup stuff. So we cover a lot of different topics related to startups and um we have a lot of different guests that are founders of other companies and um just you know if you're kind of into the startup on you're an entrepreneur it's a very educational uh podcast cool so what uh what advice would you give for someone coming out of, for someone who doesn't have a college degree or doesn't have a degree in computer science and wants to get into this field? You know, what do you think is the best way? There's these coding boot camps, there's, you know, DIY. There's always,
一些关于 Startup Hustle 的细节，那是什么？是的，它叫 Startup Hustle，你可以在 Apple 和所有你会找到普通播客的地方找到它。它是关于创业和初创公司的事情。所以我们涵盖了许多与初创公司相关的不同主题，嗯，我们有很多不同的嘉宾，他们是其他公司的创始人，嗯，只是你知道，如果你对初创公司感兴趣，你是一个企业家，这是一个非常有教育意义的播客。酷，那么你会给那些刚出来的人，给那些没有大学学位或没有计算机科学学位并想进入这个领域的人什么建议？你知道，你认为最好的方式是什么？有这些编程训练营，有，你知道，DIY。总是有，
you know, DIY and then go to a smaller company where you don't need the fancy college on your resume, right? There's all these different sort of approaches to get into the field. And it'd be great to hear your take on which one you think could be the most useful for people. Well, like almost all things in life, you've got to put the effort into it. You got to work like instead of Netflix and chill, you got to figure out how do I make a website for my church or whatever right like yeah you just gotta put the effort in and and get experience any way you can if it's like look i'm gonna find a local startup and i will donate my time uh what can i do please anything i can do i want to write some code and dedicate it doesn't matter like i need experience right and that's the hardest part
你知道，DIY，然后去一家小公司，在那里你的简历上不需要花哨的大学，对吧？有所有这些不同的方法进入这个领域。很高兴听到你认为哪一个对人们最有用。嗯，就像生活中几乎所有的事情一样，你必须付出努力。你必须工作，就像与其 Netflix and chill，你必须弄清楚我如何为我的教堂制作一个网站之类的，对吧？是的，你只需要付出努力，并以任何方式获得经验。如果它是，看，我要找一家当地的初创公司，我会捐出我的时间，嗯，我能做什么，请，任何我能做的，我想写一些代码并贡献它，没关系，我需要经验，对吧？这是最困难的部分
as a developer it's a chicken and egg problem like a lot of things right where nobody wants to hire people without experience but you can't get experience if you don't get a job and yeah all and the great thing about software development is you just need some experience and and that could be you know helping some local startup or startup or somebody else in the community, some business you know, an open source project, whatever it is, you just gotta get experience and you gotta put in the effort. And a lot of times I've had developers that work for me
作为一名开发人员，这是一个先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题，就像很多事情一样，没有人想雇佣没有经验的人，但如果你找不到工作，你就无法获得经验。是的，所有，软件开发最棒的事情是你只需要一些经验，那可以是，你知道，帮助一些当地的初创公司或初创公司或社区里的其他人，一些企业，你知道，一个开源项目，无论它是什么，你只需要获得经验，你必须付出努力。很多时候我有为我工作的开发人员
or employees that work for me that wanna do software development. And I've actually got one now kind of on my team. I meet with him and he's like, well, I really want to do computer programming. I really want to do coding. And I'm like, well, why don't you do it? You're not putting in any effort. You're not coming to me and asking me like, hey, do you have a project I can do or whatever? Like you got to put in the effort. And that's the number one problem with everything. You got to put in the effort. Yeah. So what do you think people should do to prepare, if anything? Right. So I think, you know, there's there's so many like
或为我工作的员工，他们想做软件开发。我现在团队里确实有一个。我和他见面，他说，嗯，我真的很想做计算机编程。我真的很想做编码。我说，嗯，你为什么不做呢？你没有付出任何努力。你没有来找我问我，嘿，你有什么我可以做的项目吗之类的？你必须付出努力。这是所有事情的头号问题。你必须付出努力。是的。那么你认为人们应该做些什么来准备，如果有的话？对吧。所以我想，你知道，有，有这么多，比如
there's Udacity and Coursera and then there's there's real life like like brick and mortar, you know, coding boot camps where they kind of give you a diploma at the end or get you some interviews. And, you know, the sentiment on this has been pretty mixed, right? I mean, there's some people who swear by them. There's some people who say, oh, I would, you know, I don't even look at that on someone's resume and they disregard it totally. I think that, you know, you could, you could, you can easily learn everything on your own. And so, you know, what do you think is the value of these kind of coding boot camps and you know would you advise people to try them out so i think all of these things are applicable avenues right
有 Udacity 和 Coursera，然后有现实生活，比如实体编程训练营，他们在最后给你一个文凭或让你参加一些面试。而且，你知道，对此的看法相当复杂，对吧？我的意思是，有些人发誓支持他们。有些人说，哦，我，你知道，我甚至不在某人的简历上看那个，他们完全无视它。我认为，你知道，你可以，你可以，你可以很容易地自己学习一切。所以，你知道，你认为这些编程训练营的价值是什么，你知道你会建议人们尝试它们吗？所以我认为所有这些事情都是适用的途径，对吧
so you know there is a a boot camp sort of place here in kansas city that i think is like 12 weeks long and um but it costs like some insane amount of money to go to like it's like twenty thousand dollars or something like oh wow it's some astronomically insane amount of money to go to. Like it's like $20,000 or something like that. Oh, wow. It's some astronomically stupid amount of money. But you know what? Like 90% of the people that go through it get a job. Oh.
所以你知道，堪萨斯城有一个编程训练营之类的地方，我认为大约有 12 周长，嗯，但去那里需要花费一笔疯狂的钱，比如两万美元之类的，哦，哇，这是一笔天文数字般的疯狂金额。就像两万美元之类的。哦，哇。这是一笔天文数字般的愚蠢金额。但你知道吗？去那里的人中有 90% 找到了工作。哦。
So somehow or another, they do a really good job at placing these people. And now they don't all necessarily get engineering jobs. They may get jobs doing QA or technical support or other things, but they're entry-level positions. That's the key, is getting your foot in the door somewhere and getting experience. And so, you know, I think the cost of those things are insane. But with all of these, it's like the ROI to it, right? It's like if I know if I go to this thing and I'm going to get experience and they can help get me a job, then it's really valuable. So I actually went to DeVry, which is a technical school. You end up getting a four-year degree.
所以不管怎样，他们在安置这些人方面做得非常好。他们不一定都能找到工程类的工作。他们可能会从事质量保证（QA）、技术支持或其他工作，但这些都是入门级职位。关键在于先迈进门槛，积累经验。所以，你知道，我认为这些东西的成本高得离谱。但对于所有这些，这就像是投资回报率（ROI），对吧？如果我知道参加这个项目能让我获得经验，并且他们能帮我找到工作，那它就非常有价值。我实际上去过德锐大学（DeVry），那是一所技术学校。最终你会获得一个四年制学位。
And they do a good job as well with career placement and stuff like that. But I think all of these avenues are possible. I think some of the best are working at a place and you've got like product knowledge industry knowledge of a certain thing you're like i want to teach myself programming and then like okay how do i how do i apply that where i work you know and then how do i like ease myself how do i somehow transition myself from being, you know, I work in a medical lab and I'm an expert on all things about medical lab. How do I, how do I work myself into the engineering department somehow? Right. Yeah. And that's really good advice. And, and, and that was my example earlier from Venn solutions. Like we had somebody who was a support person and they slowly work,
他们在职业安置等方面也做得很好。但我认为所有这些途径都是可行的。我认为最好的方式之一是在某个地方工作，你对某件事有了产品知识和行业知识，然后你会想“我想自学编程”，接着思考“我该如何在我工作的地方应用它呢？”你知道，我该如何让自己过渡？比如，我在医学实验室工作，我是医学实验室各方面的专家。我该如何设法进入工程部门呢？没错。是的，那是非常好的建议。这就是我之前提到的Venn Solutions的例子。我们有一个做支持工作的人，他们慢慢地……
slowly work themselves into the engineering side of it. And that's where you can teach yourself or do small projects. You're starting to work on small bugs. But a lot of times, you've got to work at the right kind of company that has the right atmosphere for those kind of people to succeed too. Yeah, I think a lot of those are startups. I think startups are a really, a really good place for people to go. And in fact, I have this this sort of theory that sort of the better you are relative to your resume, the better a startup is for you. So, you know, if you have a phenomenal resume,
慢慢地进入了工程领域。这就是你可以自学或做小项目的地方。你开始处理一些小漏洞。但很多时候，你必须在一家拥有合适氛围的公司工作，这样的人才能成功。是的，我认为其中很多是初创公司。我认为初创公司对人们来说是一个非常好的去处。事实上，我有一个理论：相对于你的简历而言，你越优秀，初创公司就越适合你。所以，如果你有一份出色的简历，
but you're not actually that good at coding, then going to a big company is probably going to work in your favor. You can kind of blend in, you know, the resume will get you through. But if you're lopsided in the other direction, you have a ton of talent, but, you know, you got a degree in economics or something. And so the degree doesn't show the computer science skill that you have. That's where startups can be a really good opportunity. I also really like what you said about starting in an adjacent role. A lot of people ask me how to get into AI, and I tell them something very similar, which is just start as a software engineer at a company that does AI in some way, shape or form. That's usually the best
但你的编程能力其实没那么强，那么去大公司可能对你更有利。你可以混进去，你知道，简历能让你过关。但如果你是另一种情况，即你非常有才华，但你拿的是经济学学位之类的。所以学位并不能体现你所具备的计算机科学技能。这就是初创公司可以成为一个非常好的机会的地方。我也非常喜欢你说的关于从相邻角色开始的建议。很多人问我如何进入人工智能领域，我告诉他们非常相似的建议，那就是先在一家以某种形式从事人工智能的公司担任软件工程师。这通常是最好的
way to start. Well, or it's like, hey, I'm a software engineer at Stackify and maybe we don't do a lot with AI, but you know, in my free time, I'm going to see how I can apply AI to what Stackify does. Yep. Right. I'm going to go back to my boss and say, look at this really cool thing we can do with AI. Yeah, totally. Cool. Yeah. I'm definitely going to check out your podcast. I just inside baseball or something. I've always wanted to start a company. It's never been. The opportunity hasn't presented itself to me yet, but it's something I've always been interested in. And I love resources like that. I follow what's the one I follow? Oh, Pivot, where they talk about a bunch of different startups. But yeah, I'll add this one to my list of podcasts. I'm looking forward to it.
开始方式。嗯，或者就像是，“嘿，我是Stackify的软件工程师，也许我们没有做太多人工智能相关的工作，但在空闲时间，我会看看如何将人工智能应用到Stackify所做的事情中。”没错。对吧。我会回去告诉我的老板，“看看这个我们能用人工智能做的很酷的事情。”是的，完全正确。太棒了。是的，我一定会去听你的播客。我一直想创办一家公司。只是机会还没有出现，但这一直是我感兴趣的事情。我喜欢这样的资源。我关注的是……是哪一个来着？哦，Pivot，他们谈论了很多不同的初创公司。但没问题，我会把这个加入到我的播客列表中。我很期待。
And thank you so much for coming on the show. So folks out there who want to know more, the tool that was free is Prefix. There's also, what is the enterprise product? It's called Retrace. Retrace. And you can get both of those at stackify.com. Check it out. And what is Python? What are the six languages that Prefix is going to support?
非常感谢你来到节目。所以，想了解更多信息的听众朋友们，那个免费的工具是Prefix。还有一个企业级产品是什么？叫Retrace。Retrace。你可以在stackify.com上找到这两个工具。去看看吧。还有Python是什么？Prefix将支持哪六种语言？
Yeah, so we support.NET, Java, PHP, Ruby, Node.js, and Python. Cool. I mean, that covers a lot of the major ones. So once that's out, maybe we'll add it to our new section of the show when that's out, so we'll remind everyone about that. And yeah, thank you so much for coming on the show, Matt. I really appreciate it. I think hopefully we really showed a lot of folks out there
是的，我们支持.NET、Java、PHP、Ruby、Node.js和Python。太棒了。我的意思是，这涵盖了大部分主流语言。所以一旦发布了，也许我们会把它加到我们节目的新板块中，到时候我们会提醒大家。好的，非常感谢你来到节目，Matt。我真的很感激。我希望我们真的向大家展示了
how this actually works and how these websites stay up. All right. Thank you for having me. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这些东西是如何运作的，以及这些网站是如何保持在线的。好的，谢谢邀请我。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的《Axo》。《Programming Throwdown》是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播作品，也可以进行重混和改编，但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。